astroturfing which sounds like a new
teen trend of artificial grass
while eating cascade pods that's right
the teens have moved on from tide it's
all about cascade now astroturf ping is
the practice of corporations or
political groups disguising themselves
as spontaneous authentic popular
movements it's basically fake grassroots
that's why they call it astroturf II
it's a very funny very clever name
now you're probably familiar with
astroturf II as a concept from C ads by
groups with a generic populist sounding
names like Americans against food taxis
delivering weirdly specific messages
like these Washington is talking about a
new tax on Jews rates of soda they say
it's only pennies
well those pennies add up when you're
trying to feed a family
Washington if you're listening but
doesn't seem like much to you can be a
lot to us
tell Congress no taxes on juice drinks
and sodas well it won't surprise you to
learn that Americans against food taxes
was not started by regular Americans
pooling their resources together to take
out a large ad buy on national TV about
their number one problem priority a
proposed soda tax no it was a front
group for the food and beverage industry
which makes a lot more sense soda
companies have a lot of money at least
enough to convince the LeBron James to
pretend he drinks sprite sprite diabetes
you can taste and and well you might
think well yeah but that's obvious I'd
never fall for astroturf like
that
don't be quite so sure because with dark
money surging in the wake of decisions
like citizens united astroturf
techniques are now becoming more
sophisticated effective and dangerous
and they are not going away so tonight
we thought it might be useful to take a
look at some of those techniques to help
us better spot them in the future
let's just start with the names
themselves because sometimes groups are
created with deliberately misleading
names for instance the group save our
tips which purportedly speaks for
waitstaff is an anti minimum wage
increase group funded by restaurant
owners the National wetlands coalition
worked on behalf of oil companies and
real estate developers and the American
Council on science and health has been
funded by among other things
fracking interests soda companies each
cigarette companies and chemical
manufacturers so it's pure straight-up
opposite world it's like if this show is
called funny time happy hour with
shuttle honks John Oliver
it's just demonstrable false we can't
back that up and look it's not
always easy to spot exactly what the
group's motive is especially with an ad
like this don't eat here
what's with your people tossing money at
the Humane Society of the United States
these HSUS losers aren't even affiliated
with your local pet shelter for more
information go to humane watch.org that
is a very strange ad because first of
all if you're going to have a talking
dog what would you make him such a gruff
hey I'm Tony and I'm mad
the Humane Society's a bunch of losers
and if you disagree you can suck my dark
dick
and second second who would take out an
attack ad on the Humane Society a rival
even humane er society puppy mills
self-loathing dogs it's impossible to
say for sure all I can tell you is that
ad is the work of Rick Berman
a PR expert who's known in the industry
as dr. evil he is known for his defences
of controversial products from
secondhand smoke to trans fats to payday
loans he's also created nonprofit groups
that have fought regulation of all of
those things in fact it's one of those
groups the concentr the Center for
Consumer Freedom which was credited on
that Humane Society attack ad so if is
the Center for Consumer Freedom a front
group full Berman's corporate clients is
it at all relevant that Rick Berman has
shown up at events for the pork industry
and industry which has been targeted by
the Humane Society in the past for the
use of gestation crates or as Rick
Berman insists on calling them maternity
pens I can't say I legally can't say I
want to are badly wanted but I've been
explicitly told I can't you can probably
guess but I can't say it out loud what I
can say is that Berman rejects any
accusation that he runs front groups for
corporate clients saying there is no
front because there is total
transparency which is a little odd
considering we don't know who's behind
many of his campaigns and that message
of transparency does seem to
significantly change whenever he's
behind closed doors because here is
audio of Berman pitching his services to
a group of oil executives people always
ask me one question you said how do I
know is that I won't be found out as a
supporter of what you're doing we run
all of this stuff through nonprofit
organization
that are insulated from having to
disclose donors total anonymity see
transparency but look look he is right
there is total anonymity and just as a
general rule if the most common question
you get asked is how do I know no one
will find out on doing business with you
that's not a great sign if the same
privacy guarantee that Hardee's gives
all of its customers don't worry none of
your friends family or coworkers will
ever find out that you've been doing
this now go and enjoy your monster
thickburger before the horse meat gets
cold
but astroturfing is more way more than
just funneling money through nonprofit
front groups groups can also recruit
questionable experts to lend their
arguments credibility there are multiple
examples of this but my favorite
concerns a group called citizens for
fire safety a few years back health
officials in California wanted to remove
a requirement that furniture contained
chemical flame retardants as they had
been linked to cancer but citizens for
fire safety produced a burn surgeon dr.
David heimbach who argued for keeping
all of those flame-retardant
requirements by telling them a pretty
memorable story 7 week old baby was in a
crib laying on a fire-retardant mattress
on a non-fire retardant pillow mom put a
candle in the crib candle fell over the
baby sustained a 50-percent burn the
entire upper half of her body was burned
oh this is a tiny little person no
bigger than my Italian Greyhound at home
she ultimately died after about three
weeks of pain and misery in the hospital
now that sounds horrifying but there are
some weird things about what he just
said first I don't know why he felt the
need to compare the size of a baby to
his Italian Greyhound
everyone knows what size our baby is
nobody's never seen a baby so wait it's
like a person but smaller tell me more
doesn't use stilts how does it board a
bus what I'm picturing is something
about the size of five hamsters taped
together a very small lawnmower a mine
around the right ballpark here but
second if part of you there was
wondering hold on
who puts a candle in their baby's crib
you're not alone journalists with the
Chicago Tribune wondered the exact same
thing and they soon discovered that two
years earlier home back and testified
before a different California panel
telling a weirdly similar story I will
tell you about a child I took care of in
April mom had a candle for sitting at
beside the bed left the room for seven
minutes for reasons we don't know the
child that candle turned over the child
sustained an 80 percent burn okay so now
this is starting to sound a little
suspicious how many people are putting
lit candles in and around their baby's
cribs oh I just put little Ethan to bed
I put plenty of lit candles in his crib
as a nightlight and I balance several
sharp knives and open cancer pain filler
right on the crib wall so he has
something to look at look look home back
wasn't done because just a year later he
was testifying before the state
legislature in Alaska and guess what a
six week old baby that I took care of
earlier this year mother went away there
was a candle on the bureau somehow the
dog knocked the candle onto the crib and
the little girl sustained this seventy
five percent very devastating burn wait
so now there's a dog involved all of a
sudden what kind of dog would do such a
thing wait a second I know exactly what
kind of dog a gruff needlessly Italian
dog like tongue
by God but God as if as if sensing that
lawmakers there were questioning his
motives
the very next centers the home back said
completely unprompted was this I am not
in the pocket of anybody that makes a
specific flame retardant now so be fair
he's actually right about that he was
not in the pocket of someone that made a
specific flame retardant he was however
in the pocket of citizens for fire
safety who paid him $240,000 for his
help and who it turned out only had
three members which were the three
largest makers of flame retardants in
the world so I call it liar liar pants
chemically incapable of catching on fire
oh and what Northey when a reporter
called the medical examiner's office
they had no record of any burn victim
matching heimbach's description
whatsoever so one of them did the next
logical thing i thought the best thing
to do was just to call him at home i
said those kids you talked about did
they all die in your hospital he said it
wasn't factual it was anecdotal and i
said but that's not what you testified
and he said well I wasn't under oath
okay okay
well first of all you're generally
expected to tell the truth even when
you're not under oath and second of all
anecdotes aren't the same as lies I saw
Keri Russell walking out of a bakery
that's an anecdote it's not a good
anecdote but it is an anecdote I saw
Keri Russell riding a dragon out of a
bakery that is a lie although admittedly
would be a way better story and look the
real problem there is home backs lies
worked that flame-retardant bill in
California initially failed thanks in
part to his testimony and and the final
and paps most controversial tool in
astro surfing relates to something that
our current president actually loves to
complain about I'll tell you what you
take a look outside
these are paid protesters folks the
protesters are paid a lot of money by
the DNC it turned out that the
protesters were used to have
we're bought for $1,500 apiece we have a
protester by the way were you paid
$1,500 to be a thug
now I can't walk it quite out there is
Trump angry or is he excited he's just
stumbled onto a job opportunity that
John Julie and Eric would actually be
qualified for but for what Russ specific
accusations were nonsense
hey demonstrators do exist which Trump
should frankly know himself because his
campaign reportedly had actors who were
paid $50 to cheer for him and his
campaign announcement but but paid
demonstrators are one of the most
infuriating tools of astroturfing just
just look at what happened last year in
New Orleans
a company called Entergy needed city
council approval for a controversial
power plant which it got not long after
a public meeting where by sheer chance a
bunch of huge power plant fans in orange
shirts turned up now it later emerged
that a PR firm working for Entergy hired
a company called crowds on demand which
recruited actors to supports in the
plants they did this with a facebook ad
which offered and I quote 60 to $200 e
dues to help with a gig for three hours
which in itself right there is a red
flag dollar e dues sounds like slang for
money that you'd find in a Mark Twain
novel called even for the 1800s there
are way too many n words in this crowd
of demands even provided talking points
such as folks this is 2017 we had a boil
water advisory here last month and I'm
tired of feeling like I live in a third
world country and it seems like some of
the people there took those notes and
ran with them I'm tired of feeling like
we're living in a third world country
this is the United States of America its
2017 going on 2018 and we have to worry
about these frequent water boil
advisories and so on and so forth I have
to be concerned that a grandmother or a
son or a pet could possibly drink or
take in some brain-eating ameba
yeah I'll give him credit for that last
but the brain-eating ameba bit was all
his own he was just riffing hard at that
point now now that man insists that he
believed everything he said and that he
wasn't paid by crowds on demand although
you should know that another person
there who does admit to being paid said
he received instructions that read a few
things to keep in mind one tell nobody
will being paid to tell nobody you're
being paid three media will be present
do not talk to them for tell nobody
you're being paid and five if somebody
approaches you don't tell them you're
being paid which are and this is true
word-for-word the vows in a traditional
Scientology wedding now if you look
they're beautiful vows and you should go
now if you are wondering who is behind
crowds on demand let me introduce you to
their CEO Adam Swart the answer to the
question what if a lukewarm bottle of
smirnoff ice was a person now now he's
he's pretty unrepentant about what his
firm does have you ever provided
protesters for an event of course
demonstrators of course do you see
anything wrong with that personally nope
do you ever feel like you're tricking
people though into getting behind
something that they may have not gotten
behind if they didn't see all this
activity there we don't trick people we
engage them yeah yeah but you engage
them by tricking them don't you both
both of those things can be true at the
same time it's like someone saying I'm
not masturbating in the middle of this
Pinkberry
I'm just engaging the police department
you're actually doing both and one
doesn't make the other okay now of
course what's whole ruse is predicated
on people holding their nerve and not
giving the game away in real time but
amazingly that has happened in the small
town of Camarillo
I think the city needs a shake of
citizens aren't shy about expressing
their opinions but one chilly Wednesday
night in December Prince
Jordan Tyson city officials say this man
stood out this case is clearly common
sense because for three minutes he told
the City Council what he later admits
was a lie I'm just a concerned citizen
coming up here and speaking to you but
he's not he's a self-described
struggling actor from Beverly Hills it
goes by the name of Prince Jordan Tyson
okay no I don't believe it I do not
believe it does anything about this face
this face say struggling actor from
Beverly Hills to you I'm sorry this
story just doesn't check out but
incredibly it's true because while they
know Toya's pjt initially claims to be
from the area he soon had a crisis of
confidence culminating in this forty
minutes later
Tyson came back to the podium Prince is
back for one of the strangest moments
the City Council has ever seen I don't
agree with the reason I'm here and I was
paid to be here how much were you paid
hundred bucks how much $100 you're
idiot Prince you just broke
ground on Tim Barnes rules one two four
and five now you won't get those
hundred-dollar e dues which could have
gone toward changing your name to
literally anything else or getting a
haircut that doesn't make you look like
an out dente Owen Wilson when you add
all of this together faith groups hiring
fake experts and fake crowds which
managed to affect real world change it
gets pretty dispiriting and it can do
real damage that goes way beyond the
narrow issues that each group is trying
to influence the very existence of
companies like crowds on demand mean
that something authentic can now be
tainted in fact conspiracy boards now
regularly and wrongly cite crowds on
demand as providing everything from paid
protesters for Charlottesville to crisis
actors for the Las Vegas shooting and
that is hugely dangerous because the
consequences of this cannot be that
everyone assumes that anyone who doesn't
agree with them is astroturf you know
what while skepticism is healthy
cynicism real cynicism is toxic and
because this problem isn't going it away
going away it is now even more incumbent
on us to use our judgment diligently if
the Ray Liotta of docks is telling us
the Humane Society is terror
it's probably worth us all asking why
why who might have trained him and what
do they stand to gain and unfortunately
until we find out a way to force
astroturf groups to be more transparent
and accountable that's about all we can
do right now astroturf is a serious
threat to our public discourse and it is
critical that we are all much more aware
of its dangers
and since astroturf furs have left all
their tools lying around at the very
least we might as well use them to fight
candle fire with candle fire and deliver
a heartfelt message we're all Americans
real people definitely not actors were
just a coalition of Concerned doctors
mothers teachers and kidnappers and we
think you deserve the truth about
astroturf furs here are the facts
astroturf furs are responsible for every
shark attack in American history wonder
all the B's have gone after jurors shot
him in the face and according to the
bipartisan Institute of factual science
studies every single astroturf fur has
killed at least one puppy with their
bare hands or maybe not we're not under
oath the point is that's what surfers
set this baby on fire that's not a dog
that's a real baby no bigger than an
Italian Greyhound
her name's Eleanor and she likes for
things but binky hood Bava corporate and
political transparency and not being on
fire and right now
Elinor is open for and if you're not
careful one day a pastor is going to
come to your house and like your baby
fire stop and structure they paid for by
citizens for fresh orange juice
you